at Judy delicious lab at the University
of Virginia while studying children's
understanding of scale researchers
discovered a very surprising phenomenon
involving self-awareness a crucial step
toward becoming a social being
two-and-a-half-year-old Madeleine is
invited to play in a room full of large
toys at this age she already has a sense
of herself and would have passed the
shopping cart test with flying colors
she's given hands-on experience with
each toy in the room researchers wanted
to know what the baby human would do if
they replaced these life-size toys with
perfect miniature replicas how would
they physically relate to them Madeleine
notices that there is something
different about the room now
why don't you pretend like it's the big
one anything get in its never arrived
but that doesn't stop her from treating
the toys as if nothing had changed
ignoring the size of the car she
proceeds to try and get into it as far
as it goes
many other two-and-a-half-year-old
children tested responded in the same
way as Madeleine did they did not modify
their behavior with the toys even though
they could see that they were smaller
so the researchers wondered why would
the baby human who by the age of two and
a half has a sense of themselves in
their own bodies ever relate to the
miniatures as if they were still
full-sized toys it seems that the baby
human wants to play with the toys so
badly it can cause them to momentarily
disregard the difference between the
size of the toy and the size of their
own body here Judi DeLoach has concluded
that at this age the baby humans sense
of scale is so fragile that their
emotions can occasionally override their
perception of themselves but their
perception of their physical self
includes one other major aspect of
becoming a social being and that is
gender